and remember waking up to a lot of
commotion when I got up and looked I in
about
say four to five
gunmen all had B clav and so I remember
getting up after hearing a commotion
seeing what I seen and
instantly started running as I run out
the
building man's been
shot
[Music]
so the early years um it was good man it
was them days where playing out was cool
you know what I mean Aki tracky beat the
letter you know what I mean
Kirby football on the roads I was a
child with
ADHD so I had a lot of
energy and I felt like like it was it
was just finding where to put that
energy was the hard thing growing up I
grew up in a area called erdington which
is in Birmingham right by Spaghetti
Junction and that area there is multi
multic
cultured and it was a tight neighborhood
this is what I remember you like you
remember the days you could leave your
door
open and then your neighbor come around
like yeah I've just come around for some
sugar whatever it is and they like yeah
have a chat with your mom and whatnot so
the negatives I would say it's very easy
to be small small minded and not look at
the bigger picture just from coming from
Birmingham feel like not a lot of people
in Birmingham leave
Birmingham so it's not until you either
travel or you have a job outside of
where you live is when you start
noticing these things which is crazy
things man and what was your family unit
like then so was my my family unit was
uh was dope still uh when I was born I
always had my grandfather in the
house lived with my mom and lived with
my brother and lived with my grandfather
so from as as from the first day I can
remember I remember my granddad being in
the house so you know what's mad as well
I still live by very certain old
morals and a lot of my mates don't get
it but I always believe it was because
the father figure around my house was my
granddad so a lot of things that I was
taught just becoming into a man or
whatever it is in life was taught from
my
granddad my house as well my mom always
worked as well always working she did
care work so she'd do a 9 to9 so my
friend's mom would walk me to school on
certain days and um family was always
into music so Dad did soer and Calypso I
had uncles that did so and Calypso my
brother did um used to to play out music
so we had a big set which is in the
house so loud music and Baseline was a
thing that was in that in the family
from a young
[Music]
agement was there anything that you sort
of witnessed were there any situations
that you remember that shaped you well
you know what's crazy growing up I lived
on a road where you witness fights it's
normal to see straighteners coming from
where I'm coming from you you handle
your business by having a straightener
and you shake your hands after it so
that was normal to see you know what was
mad there's a lot of come from the area
as well what's negative like everyone
loves cars from early and bikes
so if you can't if you ain't got the
money to obtain that it's kind of normal
in your normal nature to kind
of rub cars or rub bikes and joy ride
and like mad as a youth you take
someone's car no even care who's driving
it or whatnot and just drive it and
enjoy riding with the lads and whatnot
so I seen things that was so naughty
which I thought naughty I thought I was
a naughty kid but then when you start
going to them places you start
experiencing some serious stuff some
serious kids that your naught us is not
even a you know what I mean no level to
what it is would you would you say
there's gang violence as well in your
area 100% Birmingham is a place where
there's two sides like Crips and bloods
one's called Johnny's one's called
burger bars um still up to this day
there's um obviously younger generations
and younger Generations have' changed
their names and whatnot but it's still
the same two sides probably fighting
over things I don't even know 2011 mad
year for me still all starts with me
getting a call from my brother saying my
dad's passed away Cardiac Arrest dad did
music as well so every weekend he played
the electric guitar he'd go to a PO or
whatever Hall you know what I mean and
go and play for entertainment and he
came off stage and actually passed
away um two years before that my mom
collapsed had a
stroke so she was in like a
rehabilitation place so it was crazy my
dad uh passed away while my mom was
still in his place 3 months later my mom
passes away from heart problems as well
obviously she was ill for that but it
was just 3 months of straight
tragic and it's mad because it was like
it just hit me into a mode of where now
I've got no more parents no one can tell
me what to do or how to do it cuz I felt
like whoever could tell me before was
gone so from there after I was staying
at my mom's house on myself which was I
was 19 years old in a three-bedroom yard
which I stayed in I was a mom is boy so
I never really did much my mom cooked
she did everything she taught me a few
things in life but I was a mom's boy she
used to do a lot for me so I was in that
free bedroom y for ages just living a
wouldn't say bachelor life but just
getting
through um I think about seven more
months
later being 19 I wasn't I didn't have a
clue about mortgage whatever bills need
to get
paid uh my house got
repossessed came back from going out
tried to get my key in the door it
wouldn't go in not on the door saying
your house has been
repossessed it was crazy and you know
before we get into 2012 that same year
in February so 3 months before my dad
passed I had a
child uh which was my daughter my first
born I was 19 years of age so I had my
daughter Dad passed mom passed house
repossessed uh after everyone passed
away I started driving with no life
license and it was like no one could
tell me
anything even down to all my brothers
who used to go and see aunties uncles
I'd pull up to a family Union or
whatever it is and they like yo you
driving you ain't pass it I'm like don't
worry man I'll pass soon or whatever
ended up getting pulled I think first
time I got three points second time
three
points or six points and then six points
again I got 12 and I was banned so when
he was Bann but I just didn't care I
just kept buying cars cheap little
runarounds go get 500 quid buy a little
golf get me through and it was mad like
I was just basically living out my car
no one ever knew I'd say bye to the lads
and just go and find a nice little
parking spot to go and crank
off and then
obviously me driving on a ban one Dave
old bills tried to pull me
again that day I don't know what went
through me but I just weren't having it
and up getting into a maddest one of the
maddest police
chases two
helicopters um squeezing through ballads
doing everything bear helicopters out 45
minute Chase getting away from the chase
having to get out and Fu where a
helicopters ended up finding me in the
bush from that moment there I went from
the bush to court to
prison the judge said n now you taking
you taken the piss there's no way with
back you three times and you still
driving so he ended up sending me to
prison this was in
2014 so I've had about three years now
of hardship would you say you know what
I'm trying to
say how long did you serve then uh I
think my first sentence for what I did
for driving was 14 months what was
prison like prison for me was it wasn't
like what it was like on the movies I
don't know if you never been prison you
have a little mad Outlook
of what prison's going to be like or you
know what I mean is it like the movies
if you drop the show so a man going to
be on to you obviously it's not like
that bro it's
uh it's like I wouldn't call it a summer
camp but it's not a place to be but it's
just a place of people with likeminded
people all stuffed into one place so you
end up meeting people and obviously
there's a negative and positive about
prison as well because the negative side
of it you can keep going after you go to
prison wants and the positive of it you
can you can learn that this is not the
life
you and I feel
like that prison sentence for
me was the one that made me cuz what I
did I started writing bars anytime a
certain tune came on the radio a certain
beat I like to start writing bars I took
up some business course a maths course
I remember doing a rehabilitation
resettlement that's exactly what it was
called resettlement course so before
leaving prison you have to do a
resettlement
course first
question on that was who am I it's a
spider diagram here am I before you get
to start writing the woman goes
listen um before anyone starts writing
I'm a dad I'm a brother I'm a uncle you
can't write that I want to actually know
who you are
ended up peeping to see like oh I
couldn't write anything I remember
thinking what who am I you know what I
mean what trade have I got what can I
actually put I remember peeping like
looking at the Geer next to me he
couldn't write nothing like I didn't
know actually what to do and obviously
the woman ended up saying you know
what you can write if you a brother or
uncle or a whatever is a sibling and
everyone started writing but it was
crazy it was a deep one when I went back
to myself at night I thought how could I
not answer who am
I and I think from that day on the penny
dropped that was the question that I now
had to answer and that was the chase is
that who am
I and do you do you explain Who You Are
by chasing a trade or living for a
certain purpose I to start living for a
purpose I had a daughter at the
time
who like her mom was asking me if a do I
didn't know where I was going to get
that door from coming out of
prison I just kind of have a drive
to
become something or someone and have
some sort of mission in life and a
purpose even it was crazy I was writing
the bars that I written down in prison I
was in my my my hust I was in a hostel
at the stage so I was writing some bars
is that was that when you first started
writing then no cuz I thought like as I
said I was always family orientated was
always in music so I would do things
make my own tapes and like when the
garage Crews on the radio at that stage
the garage crew I'd get my mom's tapes
like yo got to record over this this set
was cold and then there was a bit of a
Grime scam in Birmingham where you could
go to and just drop some bars for some
wheel UPS
so there was always a love for music so
I feel like that's why when I needed I
always feel like music's my counseling
as
well I feel like when I started writing
it was just my counseling it was for me
to start writing
about things that I felt like no one
else has touched
on losing my mom and dad within three
months carrying cofins not
actually not actually saying goodbye to
someone where someone's giving you a
chance to so much things in life life
lessons that I
learned that you know what I mean that I
have to grow up as well and I feel like
that's how I do it man that's what's
kept me saying turning my pain into
strength you kind of gives you a purpose
you know what I mean not everyone gets
the chance
to let thousands or hundreds of
thousands to hear what you've got to say
or to hear your
story so I feel like it's brought me to
places in life I never expect I'd ever
visit in my life I feel like doing shows
was one thing but when you do shows
abroad or a club for
instance sometimes they have another
artist there or there's three artists on
that night that's me coming up inway
there'd be three or four artists on when
I actually done my tour my own personal
one first on Mi s the t tour and went
out and started singing certain songs
and hearing fans sing back what I've put
my heart and my soul into Blood Sweat
and Tears and gone through a Madness to
even speak about it sing it back to me
he actually the penny dropped like you
know what I'm actually filling out these
rooms with everyone and theyve come to
see me did that drive you on as well
give me the biggest
drive cuz you actually can see it
there's one thing knowing you're getting
100K views or a million views but seeing
thousands of people in one room singing
your songs back to you it's
immense obviously there was Portugal as
well what was the background on that
remember being in the Airbnb one night
um obviously cuz it's been afro Nation
it's been a long few
days so everyone was crashed out we've
been
partying um me and about let's say eight
Lads in the
Gaff so having a little chill out and
then waking up to a lot of
commotion when I got up and looked I
seen about
say four to five
gunmen all had B CLS and all had
silences this is what was crazy it was
like a
movie so I remember getting up after
hearing a commotion seeing what I seen
and
instantly started running out of the
Airbnb obviously it was just a natural
reaction like what the hell's going on
I'm a high profile I got jewelry in the
place GE is in here with guns I get out
of
here as I run out of the
building man's been
shot I remember running as fast as I can
but I remembering a loud bang buff and
my leg freezing
up I mean not
moving and
then obviously being on the floor and
whatnot I remember a few people coming
over telling me to get down on the floor
and whatnot it's a crazy experience and
just not got knowing what's going on
yeah man I actually remember running out
into the back Garden sprinting and then
cuz I remember someone coming through
the door in front of me and actually
getting into the backyard and hearing a
loud bang on my leg to stop working
I'm eating the
floor lying on the floor I remember
everyone telling me to stay down after
about let's say 2 minutes of whatever's
going on is happening people in the
house searching doing what every M was
doing I thought me being by a swimming
pool the sound of the tap running was a
swimming pool when I've looked down to
my leg it's actually my
leg bleeding like a tap remember the
sound the way it was hitting the floor
it was like a tap so now instantly in
panic
mode saying to the guy that's over there
with the gun like been shot in my legs
bleeding it me a
towel no one ain't really
listening
um I remember coming back I remember
them coming back
out had a bit of jewels on I didn't have
as much jewels on as I had on at that
time um but yeah the last thing was to
say take your Jewels off
and yeah ended up taking my bracelet my
chain couple
rings and then obviously after the they
got away I ended up going back into
houses to see if anyone else had been
shot no one else has been shot it was
just me that I got
shot legs leaking I'm thinking got to
get to the hospital got to the
hospital um get got seen too it was a
very long police was coming in there
asking me what's happened I'm so I don't
know what's upen I've just been on a
holiday someone's com in and robbed and
shot me how did the police treat you bit
weird just like told they actually knew
I was from
England they didn't actually help me the
way they should have been helping
me it like I remember coming out of the
hospital turning on my phone and the
phone ringing straight away yo you
okay my manager from I'm like why what's
going on they're like bro you're all
over Sky News you've been shot in uh
Portugal I'm like H how and obviously
thinking back the only person I told
that story was a police officer so it
was only could be the police officer
that ass sold that story on
me so yeah the whole statement that the
got was from a police
officer and yeah man my ended up
getting I remember being in the hospital
not feeling like I was getting treated
well at all and it's leaving did you
have any idea who did it didn't know who
did it I just remember a couple voices
and couple accents which is not really a
big help but what I can say is that it
definitely my life flashed before my
eyes and it was mad I had people phing
me from everywhere people posting it and
remember getting back into England and
no one coming to see me and I don't care
what anyone says I believe that when
things like this happen to you you have
some sort of
trauma some sort of fear that it could
happen again and I was going through
something and I just remember just not
feeling I want to say vulnerable but I
wasn't feeling 100
myself after the trauma started coming
out the thinking of my life flash before
my eyes and it all happened in Portugal
like it all could have went there wrong
there and I always believe it was the
wrong place wrong time because I always
believe whoever them people come through
that day was definitely not for me
and that's how I got spared that day did
you lose focus after that I feel like
now it kind of pushed me you know I feel
like it was just
after so high came
out which is one of my biggest singles
today so what I believe is sometimes
negative exposure and good
exposure it's it's it can you can make
it good I would say
that lesson there mix told me never to
mix business with
pleasure and obviously now I definitely
don't mix business and pleasure you know
what I'm saying if I'm there for a
certain amount of time why would I start
spending my own door to be at a place
you know what I mean what for yeah don't
get wrong you can have fun with your
mates and that but trust me you have to
be aware once the
bad last question I'm going to ask you
how does it make you feel looking back
at what you've achieved up to this
point yes we feel
great cuz as I said man going back to
the start I was asked who am I at a
stage of my life and I couldn't answer
it and I feel like if I was to get asked
that question now today I could wheel
off a line of things so I feel like
being able to say who am I is an
accomplishment in itself
just the
journey and you can look at it as you
want like I feel like to get to the
point of me saying telling being able to
tell someone who I am it took a long
journey it took all that's what I've
done it took me getting shot so the
reason why I called my album Redemption
I feel like because I've had a bit of
time off I believe there was so much
stuff that happened in life that I
needed time off to get to know who
really missed this and if feel like
redemption in the name alone explains a
lot like I've had to give the ears
something that you didn't know what was
missing give it you again and when you
hear it you'll know like yo this is what
I've been missing and that's redemption
in itself man it's
back having people say some good things
that are relatable just knowing that you
relate you're a voice not just for you s
if you're a voice for so much people you
know what I mean man's voice knowing
that my voice could save
someone and give them hope I feel like
that's that's the main thing man I feel
like that's the growth in itself there
man look there's not an easy way for my
n to have have bounded into my room and
told me but she just opened my door on a
Wednesday morning and said Stephen your
dad's dead he's hung himself the first
thing I did was I remember punching the
wall I was so angry got up walked to one
of my friends built spliff tried to make
sense of it and I went through a whole
spectrum of emotions